dance
can be thrown
forget away the times of when your name
gets crawled upon the wall of appalling
dead turn cokes and not invitations this
is what they will say
for your humble glasses let your glasses
wow
like a 6am
we'll walk into the sunrise
hey
yeah
baby
welcome to the world famous stuttering
john podcast
with your favorite world famous host
stuttering john melendez
how are you everybody
there's the link if you want to donate
paypal dot me slash john melendez inc
there's the venmo
there
you just have to hold your phone up and
boom
donation is
greatly appreciated
let me say hi the first in the room joni
heisenberg trump reminds us every day
what a monster he is he asked putin to
dig up dirt on hunter bud
it is
[ __ ] believable
that we have a former president who i
doubt really won
is out there
now
asking
a butcher
asking a guy
who's committing genocide
for help
yet the gqp will still support him and
kevin mccarthy and lindsey graham can't
get their head out of his ass
i'm [ __ ] believable
joni heisenberg ukraine secret service
please conceptual which shows a russian
soldier railing against the incompetence
of his own army the whole army with us
the stupid morons
trump said the united states is like a
third world country because when you go
to buy something at tiffany's they don't
have product
right the typical american is shopping
at tiffany's
carl jacobson hello prince john my
brother inbound for another great show
hello everyone
yes prince john
that's what the lauren bozo burt
calls me
human f being he really said that talk
about
living on another planet i know
i know
johnny heisenberg why did it take three
days after the will smith slap at the
oscars for the academy to reveal he was
asked to leave now there we re pause the
academy is line the academy is lying
the academy are low lifes
we have plenty to talk about today that
caitlyn jenner joining
fox news oh my god
caitlyn jenner
you're a disgrace to the transgender
community okay
okay
all the time that i argue with you when
you were bruce you were against same-sex
marriage
now suddenly you're the transgender
spokesperson [ __ ] off
thomas mcnulty like dice hold on johnny
heisenberg alan weiskopf former cfo at
the trump organization admitted that the
valuation of trump's personal residence
had been overstated
by give or take 200 million
thomas mcnulty like dice clay is the
favorite of crude and poorly educated
trump is the leader for dropouts to look
up to
true
jody heisberg good to see president
biden calling out u.s oil companies
who made 80 billion in profits last year
john bolton calls trump a lie i heard a
music term burner phones a number of
times
he was using a burner phone
people
for seven hours several burner phones
marco v 193 bob carmody
uh
the squeegee
guy collins
all right
uh
let's see
um
okay
uh
joanie heisenberg
uh
jared kushner is testifying now before
the jn6 committee
take your shot every time he pleases the
fifth
i i'd say about 300 jm vandy with the
badge mark hurley from ireland
robert myers
i hope you enjoyed your massa ball soup
stage dog
adam sulu
julie svenson
um
all my facebook people john def is here
uh during this broadcast you can support
my page by sending star as a digital
gift that helps me earn money
sherry p
my mom is here
kenny gill from melbourne australia
tammy pearson from facebook
jeanette cook
andrea mccready from ontario canada
rose monteverdi william zavala
patricia ram patrice ramsey sorry
arizona angel cat cb
long shot louie
la mason dochat
nails by sherry
patty freeburn
uh a c k t h b b f t linda mcewen
uh michelle oriamma
robin brazil yvonne watkin
uh sheryl dorbar
nancy cox russell johnson still on the
island
ricky carroll from muscle shows loves
swampers alabama
roderick berry mexicali maggie
who's gonna do the first super chat
today
uh chris derrickson howdy sparklers
ziggy
jacqueline 2020 tried to get hal on
today
but he's got to help his girlfriend who
just did a show last night patty
freeburn
mark p how are you
again hunter biden is not an official of
the u.s government nor is he running for
public office thank you
suzanne for recep i hope you're doing
okay
uh
uh
let's see
okay
um
uh
no i didn't watch house thing that the
other night
i forgot actually
um
kimberly glance from clint kent ohio
uh
captain terp jony hall
um nancy cox steve mccann debbie
garrison
uh joan hall
john causey d mccann
paula baines from oregon william nichols
naomi santiago
uh
joy hunting with the badge john
causey
uh
debbie cat roderick berry with the first
super chat
thank you roderick
uh zielinski's girlfriend is going to
the front lines to fight
it's freaking awesome
so like i always like to do
i like to bring new guests on
to the show
because
you know
i like to mix it up
i had tom arnold on tuesday i hope
everybody enjoyed it
brother ted
um i'm going to dc in april i actually
was on the phone with uh
the press department in dc
i had to make a couple of phone calls
first i was on the phone with print
then i was on the phone with um
uh
the senate's office then they gave me a
number for um
tv and radio so i have to give them a
call today
or tomorrow
uh
so i will
i will certainly uh
um but i will be there in april
gonzo's gonna meet me there and help me
out
mexicali maggie thanks for the five
bucks john i don't get paid until april
sorry so cheap love the show
look anything helps and no one's has to
do it type me but i do appreciate it
because i do have a lot of money to
spend in
when i go to dc fat chance mg daniel
if i have to put up a crew
if i have to get
you know at a hotel
the amtrak's not too much but i also got
to get yeah i got to get a crew
the hotel the flight
you know it all adds up
kimberly glons chris derekson i'd like
to get press credentials though jackie
hopson
all right but i tom arnold was awesome i
hope everybody enjoyed that i'm gonna
put it up
onto itunes
at some point uh today or tonight or
tomorrow morning i don't know but it uh
and uh that was a great show and today
is gonna be great too
i have a brand new guest
who's gonna come on and um uh
as for as from
uh popock
uh
tells me to get the guest uh
on i just saw that by scott o'grady
interview
is up on youtube that was one of my
favorites i kept saying douchebag says
douchebag says what and he kept and he
kept saying what
uh
let's see where is brett myself when i
need him
uh
come on come on midas
where are you midas oh history maybe i
haven't no i don't think i watched it
here
uh i want to play this before
uh
uh this is it okay
okay
i'll just play this first then we'll
bring on my
new guest
uh i hope he doesn't fail me
michael popock
uh has asked me and said the guy
enjoys the show
and i said okay i'll have him on so here
we go
midas touch
breaking news on the investigation into
the january 6 assault on the capital cbs
news and the washington post have
obtained white house records of
president trump's activities that day
and they reveal a nearly eight-hour gap
in entries in his call log and his daily
diary last call is recorded at 11 17 and
it's to an unidentified person extremely
vague the next call recorded occurred at
6 54 p.m
this gap raises big questions about what
the president was doing at the time and
whether he was using a so-called burner
phone maybe a couple of them those are
disposable and untraceable what is he
hiding and what is he trying to cover up
who is he trying to protect
yep
we know what he's trying to hide that he
helped orchestrate the freaking
insurrection without further ado host of
uh
fm i believe is the podcast name if i'm
if if i'm correct if not i i will now be
corrected by tony michaels how are you
tommy i'm good john how are you
good man so uh
where are you from well i'm from i'm
from the the uh the flyover part of the
country in missouri do you know the
netflix series ozark are you aware of
that of this yes yeah so i grew up about
15 miles from where that is set um and
it's not too far off so i um the part
part of that was actually filmed where
i'm from and then the other part was
filmed in georgia as we know but uh but
no that that is where i'm from is where
the the netflix series ozark that's
where i'm from
well it's so funny because i called you
because i like i don't know this dude
yeah
i got to do some kind of vetting here i
go hey
are you a lefty you're not yeah but it's
kind of it's kind of confusing because i
i don't sound like one i don't look like
one sometimes i even wear a red hat uh
and people are like oh my god you wear a
[ __ ] red hat dude jesus christ so
you know you know i like the the video
from midas touch that you just played um
speaking of brainless people who wear
red hats um you know there's a seven
hour gap in between the call log at the
white house but you know there's there's
about a seven hour gap between between
the cheeto dust mobster's ears um that's
what i call that's what i call donald
trump so
um i i like i like the video that they
did yesterday i i take it that you liked
it too
yeah i'm you know what you know i
discovered those guys did you know that
yeah well you know uh i've watched
several episodes of your show that that
they were on
um and i think i think even on when
jordy and brett came on on our show
i think it was back last december i
asked him about the midas mighty and
jordy said that the phrase was coined
right here on this show the midas mighty
that's that's where he says he thinks
that's originally
where it actually was coined was on the
show
well you know i have to give
credit to my producer because uh you
know
uh my producer royce because he
said hey this
you know
these band of brothers uh
came out with this
a video called uh are the snake
you know i i think you should have them
on i mean i don't know if it's gonna be
anything and i go yeah sure i'll have
them on
now they're like the biggest thing in
freaking you know right i mean they have
a billion shows on their network
although they haven't asked me
you're on the network
i i am so we we recently partnered with
mind as touch uh we do a two hour show
every single weekday so i go live every
single every single weekday noon eastern
11 central on youtube twitter twitch and
now we're actually broadcasting on mind
as touch facebook page because we are
partnered with midas touch in the
distribution of our show um i've been
doing this show for
i guess it's been about the 14 months
that i ran and gave on the internet it
actually started with tick tock i was
doing tick tock videos and you know
after the election when the the uh the
grandpa poopy pants the cheeto dust
mobster really wouldn't let go of the
the election he wouldn't concede he kept
selling this big lie i got really pissed
off so i started yelling into the tick
tock and people are like oh this is this
is fantastic here's a guy who sounds
like a trumper looks like a trumper you
would think trump [ __ ] would pour out of
his mouth and it just doesn't and you
know i i go the opposite direction than
the trumpism thing and that's where it
kind of evolved into a podcast and i did
longer rants and now i actually have uh
a co-host and executive producer gabe
sanchez who helps me do up all my art
and he does a lot of good videos and
so we have a lot of fun we
we we
we try to laugh
and give you political commentary all at
the same time that's what i like about
your show is you kind of you know you
try to do both
yeah and i um
you know i i i mean it is kind of
weird because you
you know you don't seem like a typical
lefty but you know who also have you
ever had brett turkin on
no i uh uh
my executive producer gabe sanchez is
friends with brett they actually i think
they went i think they have the same
acting coach or something like that i
believe uh that's kind of their
connection but they know each other
through their um some of their acting
gigs that they've done um but yeah it's
i i think i think it's a common
misconception that
not not that uh lefties look like me or
sound like me but
that you can't make an argument from the
left that you don't need like a ton of
statistics and to try to make someone
feel like a dumb [ __ ] or to try to
really bury them in all your
intelligence and all this kind of stuff
i really think that there's a way to
simplify uh arguments um for instance
we see the democrats are horrible at
messaging right but the one thing the
one thing that republicans in florida
are absolutely pissed off about about
the bill that they just signed they
signed the bill they put it in the right
that's right the reason why they're mad
like i posted did you see ron perlman's
video where he was he basically called
the desantis a pos
so i posted that on tick tock
uh on my account to spread it around a
bit to show everyone what what ron
desantis really is and the one comment i
got was oh it doesn't say don't say gay
in the bill like they're so mad the
democrats won the messaging on that
right so we didn't win the actual policy
desantis the legislator passed it
desantis signed it into law but we won
the messaging and the only reason why we
won the messaging is because we put them
on defense we were on offense on that
one and democrats do this so often where
they like oh well the line item in the
bill this the line item in the bill that
we got to have this we got to have that
when really honestly
government and politics are two
different things like
politics where you're trying to get
elected is one thing
and then actually
getting in the government and doing
policy is another so you have to use the
politics to win the argument to be the
governing body to actually set the
policy this is this is the video this is
fantastic yeah i want to play it because
uh thanks for bringing it up because i
didn't see
see it but i didn't get a chance to
watch it this is ron perlman
uh talking about uh this is his open
letter to ron desantis yes it's
hilarious
and true by the way
good morning governor desantis
around here
um
don't say gay
don't say
as the first two words
in a sentence spoken by a political
leader of a state
in the united states of america don't
say
don't [ __ ] say you [ __ ] nazi pig
say first amendment
read about it
then run for office
you piece of [ __ ]
good morning governor desantis
oh
it's it's so fantastic
what spot on ron was about ron desantis
wasn't he yeah no i i i'm so happy that
you uh told me to play that because
i mean that that's awesome
you know
i love
because i love how people will enlighten
me like that's a great point don't say
i mean you know
i mean that is the i mean that's going
against the first amendment that's right
all these right-wing loons is all they
care about is protecting the second
amendment they can give a frog fat ass
about the first one i guess
well i mean they can only tell you about
the first and second they don't know any
other [ __ ] amendments past the second
one and half the time they get the first
and the second one all [ __ ] up anyways
they don't even know what those two
amendments say um and it's very clear by
their fascism that they're trying to
spread around the country because not
only are they trying to take women's
liberty away but they're trying to take
the lgbt community's liberty away from
them and
and it's not just it's not just adults
they're doing it to children and you
know the one argument that i got when i
posted that video on tick tock is
because i post it and and i put ron
pearlman destroys ron desantis like in
really big litters
but the one comment that i got the most
was it doesn't read the bill it doesn't
say that read the bill it doesn't say
that but what the bill actually does
what the bill actually does
is make it to where a kindergartner who
has two moms right who has two moms they
don't get to say that they have two moms
right and somehow that's sexualizing
something which gender is not
sexualizing anything in this country
that's such a bunch of [ __ ] because you
get a white dude like me and a white
woman like my wife and they're christian
and they're running around
and their and their husband and wife
their no one says anything about sex
about that relationship but you get you
get a gay person man and a man a woman
and a woman are trans man and a man oh
there it's all sexualized and these
[ __ ] weirdos
are absolutely obsessed with other
people's gender other people's sexuality
and the weirdest part about it all
is you're completely obsessed with other
people's genitalia and bathrooms i have
never [ __ ] went into a bathroom
and and thought about someone else's
genitalia what are you weirdos doing
what are you doing i mean that's a great
point i i don't even yeah i don't
i can give a frog's fat ass if i'm
taking a piss and and and there's a girl
you know taking a piss in the store what
the hell do i care right i don't i mean
it doesn't it doesn't affect me at all
i don't understand all this outrage
it's like the same like
it's the same thing i like you know i
have these arguments with these guys at
the pub all the time
and
guys should look like me right they look
and sound like me no no no
are from england but they don't okay
okay okay but but but you know they're
all pissed off
that cleveland changed their name to the
guardians
and
washington changed their name to the
commanders i said dude
how does that affect you in any way
you're in l.a
and
you know and they don't have an answer
because it doesn't affect them in any
way right
and it's the same thing as you know
don't say gay how does it really affect
you
how is it really going to hurt your life
in any way it's not it well here's a
good example of the sports analogy
because you know they want to [ __ ]
[ __ ] about that [ __ ] too and you know
it's all this cancer culture when
they're the ones that are actually
cancelling [ __ ] that matters like
people's [ __ ] identity and who they
are their their [ __ ] humanity their
goddamn dignity for crying out loud
the the baltimore cults packed up and
left [ __ ] baltimore in the middle of
the [ __ ] night in wendy indiana and
no i i mean no one says anything about
that now they [ __ ] love the cults and
they love the ravens and they they don't
they can't they don't understand that
the [ __ ] that you're [ __ ] bitching
about about your freedom
the freedom to have the [ __ ] choice
of 15 frozen pizzas in the [ __ ] pizza
aisle in the grocery store that's not
[ __ ] liberty that's capitalism dumb
[ __ ] that's that's you having the choice
between one company making eight
different style pizzas to convince you
that you have the freedom of choice
that's not what freedom of choice is and
until we get to a point to where people
people who sound like me who can talk to
people like me and explain to them
without trumpism because that's that's
the issue that we have is they get all
this [ __ ] turned around because they're
not learning things that they should be
learning that's why they [ __ ] about crt
voodoo and they believe in jfk junior's
coming back i know
i have to ask you about this one because
okay now i'd love to get your opinion
tony because this is my latest
debate slash
argument
at the pub that's actually it was at the
scotland yard so
when you're when you're when you're when
you're back and forth with these [ __ ]
yeah this is okay now
look
i think will smith is a thug i think
what he did to chris rock whose hands
were behind his back was cowardice
i think he should have been kicked out
of the academy awards immediately
i think
to see people give him a standing
avoicing ovation is deplorable i think
it's
i think it's so [ __ ] up
that i can't you know it really
gives these right wing loons a reason to
hate hollywood even more right and i'll
tell you this though
now i am no fan of will smith but i was
calling out the hypocrisy because that's
what i do i can't stand hypocrisy
so
they're saying the academy should take
will smith's academy award away from
now we all know that the voting was done
before he hit chris rock right we all
know he was going to win before he hit
chris rock
you know his name was already on the
card right dick and the academy knew
that yes okay now
they're saying
well the academy should take his academy
award away from him
so i said well that's kind of strange
because
you guys all think pete rose should be
in the hall of fame
so
because you say
you can't judge him for things he did
after he was a player
right okay now so i said well
you know you can't have it both ways so
will smith didn't hit chris rock before
you know his performance in king richard
so
so how so he's like you know so now
you're going to go
like what he does after
for eternity and if he does something
stupid then
then you take the award away from i
don't know how do you feel about that to
me so there's a lot of [ __ ] to unpack
with the chris rock will smith thing we
unpacked it on our show on monday me and
gabe and i'll tell you what that um
uh i didn't i wasn't watching the oscars
and i wouldn't even know who the [ __ ]
won what if if that wouldn't happen
really honestly so um
the first thing is first
chris rock
the guy
is making a [ __ ] joke before will
smith's follow-through is done like he
is making a joke
as the follow-through is coming through
he says oh wow and he's thinking in his
mind how am i gonna because you know
that this wasn't planned
and chris rock is thinking how the hell
am i gonna [ __ ] recover from this guy
coming up on stage and smacking me he's
a comedian that's what he does on stage
he's he's performing and that's the
shittiest part about it all is will
smith knows that he's a performer this
isn't like will smith or some kind of
[ __ ] audience member or ticket holder
he's a goddamn performer he knew chris
rock was performing he knew that
but when chris rock says
he says
will smith just slap the [ __ ] out of me
the whole the whole room laughs they
think it's a joke
and that was the out for will smith even
there's a video out uh today and i think
michael rabbavor might have put it on
instagram or something someone had it up
um it shows like another another uh a
view
of jada peak at smith and when chris
rock says that joke oh wow will smith
just slap the [ __ ] out of me
she's laughing
who is
jada pinkett smith is laughing
and then
immediately immediate as she's laughing
will smith is yelling at chris rock keep
your my wife's name out of your [ __ ]
mouth or i think that's what he said
yeah he didn't even say it correctly
right keep not my wife's name out to
[ __ ] your mouth he can't even say you
know
use your prepositions
well here's the thing
is that today they're saying that the
academy is investigating this and i
guess the academy uh supposedly asked
him to leave which is probably oh he did
because
i have maintained chris rock did not
write that joke and
and john feels saying oh you're talking
you're talking about the one that pissed
off will smith yeah and john was like no
he improved that well i did some
research
now now
according to the according to sources
amy schumer gave him that joke well so
that that's a good question because uh
when it all happened because i was
talking to some of my friends and my
wife i was like chris rock chris rock
has hosted the oscars several times and
chris rock doesn't write every single
one of his jokes even in the shows
everyone knows that that's right for the
academy awards they write as the show's
going on right they they look at who the
crowd they write jokes for people and
they hand it to the and they hand to the
teleprompter guy or they'll just
tell it to the host or to whoever's
going to perform i had maintained chris
didn't write that joke i could be wrong
right maintain because he went from the
javier bar damn that's right to wilson i
don't think they wrote either that's
right straight to the gi j because they
were sitting next to each other i do not
think chris rock wrote it nor do i think
chris rock knew that jada pinkett smith
suffered from alopecia and
i
i also think will smith's an [ __ ]
right and
the punishment did not fit the crime
because you know if you're at an event
like that expect to be ridiculed
you know
that's what uh
gervais has done time and time again
well chris rock did it to people when he
hosted the oscars for yes and he's made
a day to picket smith before right right
look look i'm really pissed at freaking
will smith not for hitting chris rock
i'm pissed because of after earth
that's a shitty minute
well no you know that
the crazy part about the the joke
progression that you're talking about is
because it does make sense now chris
rock is good enough that he could work
that room in you know improvisational
and he could tell those jokes but i
think you're right i believe that it was
written now rather he wrote it or
someone else i think it was written
because he was going in the order of the
tables and those were the order of the
jokes yeah he was transitioning he
transitioned to javier and he
transitioned to will smith and then back
to will smith and then and then to
uh jada pinkensmith now rather he knew
about her hair or not you know i guess
who the [ __ ] knows we'll never know that
but the the point that i was trying to
make about chris rock actually telling
the joke now it's not really a joke but
he was trying to recover he said will
smith just smacked the [ __ ] out of me
and the entire room laughs because chris
rock said it in his cadence he you know
he was trying to recover and will smith
if he would have just sat down and just
played it off
uh jada pinka smith was laughing at that
joke
chris rock could have moved on they
could have been backstage and everyone
would like was that real or was it stage
and no one would have [ __ ] known no
one would have known but why acting like
an [ __ ]
i'll tell you tony i am so sick
of the amount of people like this chick
giselle on facebook
she keeps on saying it with stage
just just chick you know gisele she's
just some
hot
hot girl i follow
she says
it was staged she's she's like
guaranteeing it i'm like giselle why was
it staged it was not engaged
trust me
it was not staged this is not
this is not a staged thing
it was it was in the last 30 minutes of
the award show they're not trying to
boost ratings in the last 30 minutes it
was not staged it was
will smith being an [ __ ] and let me
tell you one more thing to this [ __ ]
douchebag
i don't know what uh joe partel or
whatever his name is
you know like who won for best
documentary as a producer after chris
got slapped he said uh you know
he said like and then the four produces
a black guy and then and then three
you know and three white guys and he's
so mad that he his name wasn't said and
i tweeted this idiot today i said
dude
did you ever think that chris rock was
kind of in shock that he just got
slapped in front of millions of people
and really just wanted to get the hell
off the stage and just get out of there
yeah it was will smith that caused this
guy not to have his name said not
[ __ ] chris rock
yeah will smith i know so he he's
calling chris rock and f an [ __ ] so i
tweeted him of course i said hey guess
what
you're and then he says that
you're all are weirdos i go no dude
you're the weirdo the guy just got hit
do you really expect him to
to show any kind of decorum after that
i'm telling you i know chris rock he's a
nice guy
and i've been hit before when you get
hit
it's
like
you know it's such an invasion of your
privacy of your space
and you know you don't know how to react
at first
you're kind of in shock because you
don't know and i'm telling you chris
rock and then they issued some
some idiot issued a fake chris rock
apology
it wasn't chris rock's apology chris
rock has nothing to apologize about this
is all
will smith he should own it
the academy should ban him forever from
showing up at an award show they're
cowards for not telling him to elite
for telling him to leave and any
freaking producer who's so butthurt that
his name wasn't mentioned has got to
know that
that quest was kind of traumatized at
that moment by getting hit by a guy a
foot taller than him in way better shape
than him who starred in ali
i mean come on who who trained to fight
give me a [ __ ] break i'm so sick
but getting back to my analogy
do you understand how i think it's
hypocritical they say take his award
away but but allow pete rose to be in
hall of fame it doesn't make sense to me
no it doesn't well and and i i don't
think that the academy is gonna take his
award away no they haven't taken away
harvey weinstein they didn't take away
woody and they're not gonna take his
[ __ ] award away they're not going to
and and now and that's why i i know that
they didn't ask him to leave because
they let him go up on stage 20 minutes
later get his oscar now they may they
may sanction him or whatever you know
from here on out but they ain't gonna
take that [ __ ] oscar away from him
they're not going to because that that
moment is the moment that everyone will
remember about that oscar is that moment
and if you if you watch
uh chris rock if you watch it back
when he gets hit and then
will smith yells and chris rock he's
just he he wants to [ __ ] dig and he
could man he's a comedian that's what he
does
no and he's a great comedian
uh
uh
roderick berry uh thanks for the five
bucks jada pushed him to his breaking
point true
she messed around on him put it out
there in the open marriage she still
loves two packs she has a shady past i
agree i i do agree i don't know how that
started if she cheated first then they
had an open marriage or it was the other
way around i don't really give a [ __ ] um
baby yoda thanks for the two bucks
uh
uh
no you know and then i get it you know
you know a horrible troll you know oh i
love the trolls do you like the trolls
john i love the trolls yeah you know
it's just you know when they say stuff
about my transgender kid it's it's oh i
see
they when they go after kids they're no
longer a troll they're an [ __ ] and
[ __ ] need to be need to be
let out of the building with their head
opening the door
but it's cowardice because they do it
anonymously if that idiot
would do it to my face right you know
what i mean well let me tell you
let me tell you something about the
chris walk will smith go to one of my
gigs and do it to my face
and then we'll see how how tough you are
right
well i love that i mentioned them so i i
try not to
well i'll tell you that
where i'm from in the part of the
country that i'm from if
if i would have been chris rock in that
situation will smith would have made a
really big mistake by turning his back
as soon as his follow-through was done
um i'm telling you
chris rock's he had an envelope in his
right hand but that envelope would have
been laying on the floor and so would
have will smith uh with a with a right
hand because um he was wide open wide
open to be laid out
now
chris rock's probably got a little more
couth than me so you know that's
probably why will smith get out you know
i'll tell you something tony
when i was slapped by aj benzer you
should watch it on youtube yeah
i went after him
like i'm freaking bad out of hell man i
i was swinging and aj
after you know he wrote me an apology
email and he said dude
when i saw the way you
came after me i realized i was about to
get my ass kicked yeah
because
because i ain't gonna take that [ __ ] you
know what i mean i mean
so now
mind you i got hit by raquel welsh
so i'm not going to go a little
differently
well that's a little different than
getting hit by will smith you know yeah
her age i mean it's a little different
but chris rock you know
i i'm telling you tony he was stunned oh
yeah he was done so you know you can't
and he's on a national stage
you know everybody's watching and
he's not a violent guy he's not a
fighter right i mean you know he's
actually i'm telling you i know chris
rock he's one of the sweetest guys in
the world and he's one of the greatest
comics that we've ever had oh yeah
so you know and i really feel bad for
him and and and i really love the
academy because they're cowards too for
not immediately banning him for not
immediately telling him to leave
you know and right now they should ban
him lapd
should arrest will smith for assault and
bear assault and battery but they
haven't even done that will smith is a
bully
well you know um kathy griffin i think
tweeted this she said that this this
really the other thing that this does is
sets a really dangerous precedent that
not not just for for celebrities to do
this but for like you know ticket
holders at a stand-up comedy show like
you do um to have their viral moment
where you know they would go on stage
and slap a comedian and put it on film
then try to put it on social media to
have their vibrant viral will smith
moment and that that really i think
that's a really
uh valid point from
uh
from kathy and why any comedian that
that comedians
would have to put up with that [ __ ]
i'll tell you tony the uh stand up
new york already put something on their
window
if you
you know
comedians serve a purpose right they're
here to make light of the times that
we're in and make observations
of you know of things
if
if you plan on heckling
or
coming on the stage you will be escorted
out immediately and
somebody started heckling chris rock at
his latest show yeah and they
immediately
kicked him out and arrested him really
because he because i see was that in the
news
yeah i just saw it and
and chris you know had his bodyguards
come on stage because now
she actually have bodyguards with him
all the time now for these [ __ ] yeah
but that's the door
that will smith just opened right
right because now when we're on stage if
we
insult anybody
will smith has now given them the right
to think that they can come on the stage
and freaking you know and go to puncher
right i gotta start training again in
case i pissed somebody off while i'm on
stage
you got to [ __ ] defend yourself huh
patrice ramsey chris had a childhood
experience with being scared of being
bullied he went to school with a brick
one time because he was so scared that's
the side we saw
uh when he was slapped he said and that
is
because that's see without even knowing
that i know that's chris rock he's not a
violent guy right right and you know he
would never go and retaliate i'm
different because i was bullied by the
best and i'm waiting for you there's no
way there's no way will smith wouldn't
have been laying on that stage of it put
it this way tony howard stern
while he was my boss
told me
to abort
my child
because i wasn't fit to be a father now
i'll tell you
it took every ounce
of my being to not get up and freaking
punch the pelican in the face for saying
that
and the only you know but i showed the
restraint right okay
will smith
did not show any restraint and he was
laughing at the joke until jade that's
right well that's what i'm trying that's
what i'm trying to say is he was
laughing at the joke he wouldn't do what
he did and then when chris rock said he
slapped the will smith slapped the [ __ ]
jada pinka smith was laughing and that
video is out there on the internet for
people to go find of her it's a
different angle it's from a cell phone
it's someone it's someone sitting back
away from them uh several tables back
but they're taking a cell phone video of
it and you can see jade is laughing when
when chris rock says will smith slap the
[ __ ] out of me she's laughing um well
you know what then i'm going to say this
right now tony jada you're a horrible
person too
i mean
it's it's part of the german
what she would be laughing for jada
chris didn't know about your you know
disease
i didn't know about your disease and
everybody i talked to in hollywood
didn't know about your disease not
everybody follows every single aspect of
your life
sorry i just thought that you liked your
hair short some women do
marco v 193 thanks for the 10 bucks rock
tells the story about seeing an old
bully of his working security on top
five he just walked by and nodded at him
he's a stand-up guy he is
i gotta ask chris to come on the show
yeah he's good you should have christmas
you should have chris he ain't doing
anything now but i really gotta ask him
because
you know cause i i i stand with him i
stand with wanda sykes
who i love who who's another brilliant
comic who said
it was it was shameful
it was she was nauseated at seeing what
will smith did and she said that on
ellen i mean
look the whole comedy
you know just like we all stand with
ukraine i think the i think the comedy
community all stands with chris rock on
this well yeah i mean it's it's hard
it's hard to say that that him being up
there performing during his performance
where he's telling jokes and he's
digging on people and they know that
they they know that's what the that's
what the the shtick is at the oscars
while while a comedian is presenting
they know that and and and he went
through the progression
and really whether the joke was
distasteful or not it doesn't deserve it
it doesn't deserve to someone who would
cost him on stage um
you mentioned someone was escorted from
a comedy club i we there used to be a
comedy club here in missouri central
missouri in colombia did you ever play
deja vu uh in columbia missouri um
yeah it was all over again right well so
so i i
yogi babera has a famous quote it was
deja vu all over again yeah yeah
well so i so um it's kind of like a
dance club but they play they used to
have comedy i don't know if they do it
anymore um i don't think they do the
comedy party anymore but we used to go
to comedy shows
and you if you if you even sounded like
you booed they would pick you up and
take you out of that club good there was
there was no there was no ansis or butts
they would remove you from the club
almost immediately they didn't care how
many drinks you were buying how much
food you were buying um i had a friend
escorted out of there um because he
wasn't booing but he was really drunk
and he sounded like he was booing
he might have been barfing i don't know
maybe i can't remember i can't remember
this only a long time ago but they um so
i'm not sure is there a lot of comedy
clubs that let people just continue to
heckle and heckle and heckle still yes
yes yeah i mean you know i i've
i've been at some i mean you know it's
i don't really get heckled like you know
because i'm so incredible hold on kevin
murphy um how much more oxygen is gonna
be given to the slap
kevin okay let me just okay kevin
the reason why
it's getting oxygen because because
nothing has been done to reprimand will
smith when
if if he's
if he is reprimanded much like jen the
insurrection is still getting oxygen
because trump and his cohorts have not
been held accountable and it'll continue
to get oxygen until accountability takes
place and i'll keep talking about it
because it was wrong and it was violent
and we don't need that at an event that
celebrates peace love harmony laughter
and
and all these great people who put their
hard work and blood and soul into making
these films so no sorry
carla h thanks for the two bucks have
you ever been attacked by an audience
member i i have never
you know and i made mistakes you know on
stage i mean like
i guess the biggest one tony that i've
always been embarrassed about i asked a
woman once
you know how many months pregnant she
wasn't she wasn't pregnant oh [ __ ] buddy
oh my god man that's the one thing you
don't do you don't oh i learned my
lesson
did she come after you
no no no no no she goes oh i'm not
pregnant and then i just said oh i was
just kidding yeah
oh my god
you dodged a bullet oh yes but i felt
horrible about it right
i mean that's the thing if i ever say
anything bad to an audience member like
that's way like you know a below the
belt out
after my set like and i normally don't
anyway but i'll go up you know like to
them and apologize right because you can
feel it you can feel if you say
something that may may or may not have
crossed over
you're just telling jokes but you're
just telling jokes yeah
you know i'll just say i'm so sorry if i
hurt you you know because that's the
kind of guy i'll buy him a drink i say
that was wrong but i don't but i don't
really do that because most of my act is
just goofing on myself you know what i
mean right right well you know uh here
this week i actually got a dm from our
show this week um i called marsha
blackburn the c word a lot of people
don't like the c word um i very rarely
use the c word but there are a few
people out there that deserve to be
described as the c word and i usually
don't get a lot of flack because they're
like oh marsha blackburn i'm not i'm not
for someone using that word but when you
talk about her that's fine you know they
kind of let it slide but i did get a dm
the other day someone's saying hey i
don't really like that word and
and i was i was thinking about it it
made me think about that just now
because i said it on i said it on the
show
um and and it made me think that yeah
maybe maybe i should consider whether i
say it or not but i apologize that
person i said you know i'm really sorry
i i just it makes me think back to like
uh rickles like when he because he would
he would absolutely burn someone's house
to the ground in front of him i wonder
if he ever like if he ever knew like
when he stepped over or if he knew he
always stepped over not like because he
was always like good-hearted you know
what i mean even on the dean martin rose
don rickles at the end would always say
just kidding uh you know i love you and
i mean i mean that's right after actor
is after his yeah
jokes and you know what
really if will smith because he ruined
his whole reputation now right right
really if if he would have just like
john
said on this show if he would have just
like
you know you know grabbed the mic and
said
and said chris
my wife suffers from alopecia i'm sure
you didn't know that but it was wrong i
wish you'd take it back and honey i love
you right he would have been a hero oh
yeah well or he would have said
something like you know my wife suffers
from alopecia and there's a many people
around the world that do and it's an
instinctive joke i don't think you
should tell it i think you should
apologize to the world chris and if you
apologize i think the world should
accept your apology and sat back down
and then chris walked chris rock could
you know he would have apologized
well and he would he would have ripped
on it and he would have made it he would
have made it light-hearted good-hearted
and he would have made it funny too
because it's chris rock and yeah but he
would have said i'm so sorry i didn't
know right and you know and jada i'm
really sorry and then it would have been
over right and will smith like you said
would have been the hero and and
everyone and people would have been
attacking chris for the joke and then
you know we could have this debate
rather
you know it was fair that he told the
joke and the apologize type [ __ ] you
know that's the debate we'd be having
instead of did he visit why did will
smith physically assault chris rock
because of a joke
ziggy says i should read the uh
a ricky
gervais um
uh
statement i gotta do that benny loco
where you been thanks for the 10 bucks
if you're here and you're having a
thumbs up what the heck you're waiting
for i could have used you today there
benny i've been getting control after
troll they're really loving me
oh you know i always hold that a lot of
trolls in the comments yeah but uh but
tony it's because they're obsessed with
me oh that's good
yeah well which is kind of a compliment
yeah that's how i feel i got i have i
have my own hate watchers we have we
have hate watchers that come hate watch
us and you're like hey man i love having
you here i look keep hate watching every
single day make sure you hate watching
give us the views yeah the whole entire
show it's like you know
it's like
if you don't have haters then you
haven't made it well yeah like i guess
because you have more than me
you know it happens that way maybe i'll
get more uh roderick barry thanks for
the three bucks and
and you're exactly right before he told
the joke chris said to jada i love you
so like like he was like he was saying
this is all in fun
come on come on [ __ ] grow a pair
please i mean this you know this is not
this just you know this is the place
where you know everyone's gonna
you know that everyone's gonna goof
around i mean that mean you know that it
should be fun and light-hearted well you
know uh the other thing too that i
noticed about like in the moment
that i noticed about it when chris told
the joke there was obviously a lot of
people in the audience didn't know she
had alopecia and there were some that
did because it didn't land very well
because you could even tell chris had to
recover a little bit because he's like
oh come on
it wasn't that bad you know he kind of
had to try to recover a little bit and
then that's when will smith came up
right
the thing that i want to see the footage
that i want to see
is after chris rock tells the joke and
will smith is laughing what it what is
the exchange and what changes his mind
does does jada say something to him does
he work at jade does he change his mind
what what happens in that moment that's
what i want to know all i could say is
i'm this is my guess
will looked over at jada saw her pissed
yeah and then said oh i got to be i got
to be the man now right right right he
had to really come to a rescue there
thanks jake james for the five dollars i
appreciate it
i'm going to dc tony all right i'm going
to try and yeah you know i want to do
the stuttering john 2.0 tour okay where
i interview politicians and ask them
goofy questions okay
like you know
like you know uh
uh uh a marjorie of green do you have
three names
to match the amount of toes that you
have on each foot
i call her i call her marjorie her foot
green
yeah
that's me i call her hoof foot you
should die
you shouldn't
you should ask lauren bobert for a
diarrhea sandwich uh recipe you should
ask her for the
have you heard that
never heard that story no she runs a
restaurant in colorado right yeah yeah
so so they were having like a street
fair and they had like a tent where they
were serving loose meat sandwiches you
know like sloppy joes or something
and they gave out these sandwiches and
it got everyone sick got everyone sick
yeah i'm not kidding you gave him
diarrhea so you should you should look
into that story that way when you when
you find her you can ask for her
her diarrhea sandwich recipe
well i want to ask you know
what mitch mcconnell all
questions that
i revolve around a turtle like like
mitch
when you masturbate is that called
turtle waxing
uh
mitch
um
is this whole thing between you
and
you know between you and nancy pelosi is
that like a shell game you're playing
that
it's gonna be all like you know mitch
you know why don't you come out of your
shell and say something nice about you
know joe biden you know i'm just gonna
be all about turtles is this whole thing
is everything going on in politics now
kind of like the tortoise in the hair
it's going to be
it's going to be all turtle jokes
and i'll see how long
that he it'll take him to finally
realize
i'm freaking turtling him
oh man mitch if you fall over can you
get back up
i like the turtle jukes i like it i like
it i like it so when are you doing this
i mean tortoise reform
yeah well i mean you know you gotta have
you gotta have tortoise reform how would
you
it's gonna be all
turtle jokes that's good that's what are
you doing this dc tour when you uh april
april april oh yeah that that'll be good
i'll look out for it i'll look out for
it then
uh benny loco thanks for the five bucks
towards the cool hat fund john thank you
sweetheart um
so yeah you know if anybody has any good
uh questions and jokes you can always dm
them to me
uh
you know when mitch drew peacock or
mitch tate needs a dump is that a turtle
said
john
jenny bringles john jokes are totally
awesome
hey
army major say hello to tony michaels
what's up tony how you doing how are you
doing how you doing sir
staying busy i'm rocking my i'm rocking
my my ukraine shirt today the one that
zielinski wore at the zoom it's pretty
cool oh really cool sweet
stand with us buddy
all right man this is awesome
that's great that's great do you have
any news out of uh i don't mean to take
over john show here but do you have any
news out of the uh
the ukraine i know
i know uh i've seen this morning there
was a missile that uh went to key i
think in kiev is uh
is that is that right is was there a
strike
in the center of
i haven't heard anything as of today but
i will tell you that you know as a
person who spent 24 years in the
military you can see
that the
the russian military has no
non-commissioned officer corps
uh and and if you look at some of the
things right now they're talking about
the soldiers that were digging in around
chernobyl
remember that that part of the earth
was never to be
messed with
that's how dangerous it is even the
people that are experts
have to have you know certain types of
equipment and russia has just basically
went through the red forest and dug in
and now they're saying that russian
soldiers are already showing symptoms
you know i'm telling you right now
within the next five to ten years you're
going to see a significant amount of
people that were in that area that are
going to be coming down with serious uh
cancers and things like that i mean it
amazes me that we thought they were
number two they are a paper tiger at the
end of the day they're an incompetent
force and they don't know
hey before we go any further army major
are you a betting man
hell yeah check out that hairdo brother
if the monks are playing
college basketball has determined the
top teams for the final four and will
determine this year's national champion
this coming week looking to wager these
games head over to your website you use
your mobile device to sign up today and
receive your 50 welcome bonus on your
first deposit just use our promo code
clns50.clns50
to get started bet online.ag remains
your number one spot for all your
updated odds and information along with
player props and great contests
throughout the year your continued sauce
for all your sporting wagering needs
including live betting and your favorite
vegas casino and poker games it's super
easy to get started so join today learn
why everyone is saying bet online.ag is
the fastest and easiest way to age on
all the popular sports and games bet
online.ag where the game starts and uh
now we get back
to the show here with tony michaels and
the army major richard ojeda uh i'll
tell you richard tony uh said he's a fan
of yours he would watch you on my show
on yeah i've watched you several times
on on john's show and i i i've been
following you on tick tock i've watched
your tick tock videos for a long time so
uh they're fantastic i appreciate that
you know i mean like like all of us man
we have to do our part you know we can't
sit silent
uh and no matter what you know you may
not think it's much but when you do a
small video or something like that and
and people see it and they share it you
know
it's it's it's given us the ability to
feel like we're still being able to get
our our punches in
uh and and that's what we all need to do
and everybody needs to continue doing
that uh we have a lot of people out
there that we need to wake up and
hopefully here soon we're going to start
to see people finally see the light i
mean you know we're listening to donald
trump who who now you know he comes out
says he doesn't even know what a burner
phone is but yet you know uh john bolton
has said yeah many times he talked about
it and in in depositions he's talked
about burner phones and then now he says
i don't know what that is
the man is incompetent and he's not even
smart enough to realize that before you
say i have no clue i've never no know
what they are you might want to think
hey did not talk about that before
donald trump is pure incompetence and it
really sickens me that we have so many
people in this country that are still
going down that path
well before we go any further i want to
play the latest from the lincoln project
uh this is
last week in the republican party
real fortune ding ding
oh hey we're gonna have kind of a
sexual get together at one of our homes
you should come they're like
what did you just ask me to come to yeah
and then you realize they're asking you
to come to an organ and i am going to
burn in hell
apparently i'm a woman santa is so so
smart he's like a death eater from harry
potter i say just being all gay people
is this a dominion voting machine is it
dominion voting mission what's this
thing doing here i mean when i found out
does anyone know when who employed
darwin where darwinism comes from they
weren't here they were for me and he
said i don't like so sir and i think we
should recognize that the
jackassery we often see around here um
is partly because of people mugging for
term uh camera opportunities property of
god's tommies i'm doing it from around
here oh what's this what's this say
don't believe the gospel jesus okay all
right all right come on
working in washington's like the worst
job in the world i never want to go that
close to the mason dixon line in my
entire life the ocean will rise one
hundredth of one percent over the next
300
years and i'm going to nominate donald
trump for speaker of the united states
house of representatives i don't care
about the eastern border ukraine i don't
i just don't you can ask her about the
weather she's going to take it right
back to our stolen election but women
shouldn't even wear pants
boom that's it
just got off the horn with the
constitution
wow so brave of him oh he's such a
[ __ ] tough guy isn't he oh absolutely
you know you can't make this [ __ ] up
nope
but the bad part about it is there's so
many people that still follow these
freaking jackaloons you know first and
foremost you know i love the fact that
now
madison cawthon is apparently walking it
back and understand you know does he try
i'm asking the questions that everyone
wants to know is he watching
first and foremost no democrat on the
face of this earth would go within
freaking 50 feet of madison cawthon
unless they were going to get a shot and
punch him in the friggin face
so him telling people about offering
orgies and cocaine so basically the
groups that you hang around with madison
cawthorn are a bunch of freaking drug
addict friggin pervs and then
kevin mccarthy gives him a bunch of [ __ ]
and and now and now all of a sudden you
know here's the thing it was either true
and the republican party do participate
in orgies and and and members of the
party snort cocaine or madison cawthorne
was a friggin complete and utter liar
and therefore doesn't deserve to be in
congress anyway so you know i mean
i don't know what i don't know what to
say i it just amazes me
that these people are in the positions
that they are and how lo how much they
lack intelligence
to do their job it's it's it's
embarrassing
you know i tweeted out um if i was gonna
have a cocaine fueled orgy i damn sure
would invite republicans like that would
be the last that would be the last group
of people that i would invite to my
cocaine-fueled orgy that's what i had
all i'm saying
yeah
talk about a downer right right right
right right it's supposed to be fun at a
cocaine field orgy that's really
listen dude listen to a [ __ ] about all
kinds of if i saw mitch mcconnell naked
i swear to god i i don't
you know i don't think i could ever
get that image out of my head
how dare you john put that in our head
now
that would be awful uh let's get to you
know i'd like to get the army major's
opinion on this yeah um
donald trump asked putin a murderer now
to
find
information that he could you know
sabotage joe biden with
and
the russian defense
ministry is now putting out
false joe biden propaganda along with
false putin propaganda i mean donald
trump
actually went
to the leader who's committing genocide
for a favor
yeah well first and foremost and like
they said this is not the time to be
trying to you know get into a
partnership with the person that is
absolutely murdering women and children
and and sending missiles into freaking
apartment complexes and things like that
you know vladimir putin is a criminal is
what he is but you know what do you
expect it's donald trump donald trump
you know thinks that that they're going
to dig up this information and that's
they're already running stuff on russian
state tv basically talking about we need
to help get donald trump back in power
you know because why because vladimir
putin
failed miserably in his friggin attempt
to to basically invade a sovereign
nation so
you know the way they looked at it is if
donald trump was the president he would
be helping us he would probably be
trying to deploy troops to russia to
help fight the ukrainians you know i
mean that's where we're at right now and
it's absolutely sickening donald trump
is a sickening individual and and i'm
going to tell you it's coming you know
every single day more and more people
are waking up
and it's not hard to see
what's coming and and the evidence is
going to surface for everybody
and you're still going to have a a small
group of people that are never going to
believe anything they're going to
continue believing the my pillow guy
forever and who gives a [ __ ] you know
those people are are are a lost cause
and we shouldn't worry about those
jackaloons but i think that
even people in the republican party that
have
intelligence whatsoever between their
ears are really starting to see it
donald trump's not going to win in 2024
he's not going to run in 2024. the
republican party does not want him to
run in 2024.
the only thing he'll be running for is
away from the cops
he should be
he should be jailed by in jail by then
but i mean look about this right now
donald trump is selecting people that he
is endorsing
and the only way to get donald trump's
endorsement is that you're going to
campaign on not bringing opportunities
to your area on not fixing the roads and
bringing broadband and and helping your
state you have to run on donald trump
was robbed in 2020 and we're gonna right
the wrong that's all he wants that's all
he wants to hear and those people are
going to lose but the best part about it
is those people are going to cause the
other republicans running to have to
dump a [ __ ] ton of money to try to beat
them and then they got to dump a [ __ ]
ton of money in the actual uh general
election look at the governor's race in
georgia he's backing purdue who's the
freaking insider trading sack of [ __ ]
that absolutely
is a complete and utter oxygen thief and
he's doing it against brian kemp who is
the republican governor who actually
has done some things that are not too
damn bad uh but at the end of the day
let them drain their money so that
stacey abrams can come on board and kick
the [ __ ] out of everybody and we may be
able to see
that maybe there's a possibility that
we're going to see some
african-americans in georgia in areas
that have a hard time winning
actually win you know and and marcus
flowers is a key example of that you
know he's doing everything and anything
that he could do and he's doing it right
so we have to hope that that's what it
takes to get that section of georgia
that technically is about as white as a
piece of paper so we have to hope that
the people realize that marcus flowers
would be far better than the person
who's done nothing over the past two
years
um t wheeler zero eight one four
uh trump was impeached
for asking uh zielinski for a favor now
the following was asking putin for a
favor i mean
he wasn't really i mean i mean at the
end of the day he was impeached for
withholding aid that was already
basically earmarked for ukraine
specifically for he was asking him for a
favor well yeah
defend themselves against russia which
you know
back to the statement that he made i
almost believe and i've surmised this i
don't know this for sure but i feel like
that trump would have never come up with
that [ __ ] on his own he was like
because you don't remember the original
one he was like uh russia if you're
listening there's 30 000 emails so now
it was emails now it's a laptop now it's
a paycheck from some mayor somewhere i
actually think that statement was
written for him to say that on trader tv
i don't know what this news network or
whatever the hell they call it but i
call it trader tv uh on my show and i
think i think that that script was
written for him what what do you think
and you know what you may be absolutely
correct on that but i'm going to tell
you something that he needs to be scared
of because right now he says you know
hey find me information about hunter
biden
but there's another organization that
the last thing you want is them coming
after your ass and i've saw many of
these posts that says hey anonymous can
you find us that seven and a half hours
worth of missing call log you know and
let me tell you something anonymous is
not the group to mess with uh you know
and they're kicking people's ass and and
i love it and uh just some good news for
all of you
um
truth social
is down 93
on subscribers
hey evan nunez leaves his post as a
congressman to head that pile of [ __ ]
i wrote that down earlier i'm going to
talk about that tonight i'm like i'm
like wow you know i'm i'm i know right
now that devin unit is so happy that he
decided to you know walk away from
congress you know true social if it has
trump's name on it i don't give a [ __ ]
what it is you know everything that has
done donald trump's name on it fails
truth social trump stakes trump
university trump organization everything
trump wine trump water
yeah i mean think about it that's that
has been that that has donald trump has
had his name on has failed and it's
amazing how there's still people in this
country they're like he's our man he's a
failure the guy fails in everything that
he does and then
he's once again he's not smart
to talk as well that he thinks he is
that's the thing a person that is so
stupid that he thinks he's so smart that
he can talk his way out of [ __ ] and he
only has a 40 [ __ ] word vocabulary
sad
tony you're getting a lot of love
goodness gold just following you and
chrissy
z0117 i donated tony michaels is
adorable thank you
uh
see that's why i love bringing new
people
i love to bring new people on because
you know it's always
it's always cool to have a fresh face
army major i had tom arnold on yesterday
i think you lost him
oh there there there he is yeah
you know he's in a trailer right now so
you know
not only that but it's also we're expect
it's been raining real bad and we're
expecting big storms all day today so
yeah we're in campers uh on our property
but anyway i had tom arnold on yesterday
really
yeah
it was awesome he was great
hilarious
yeah he he's still trying to find the uh
the apprentice tapes where donald trump
is using the n-word i mean it you know
robert nets a piece of [ __ ] because
really he should release that stuff
because that'll bury trump although the
trump supporters they'll probably love
it
right
they would they would they would love to
hear that tape of him saying what he
said at the apprentice and everyone
knows that he said it i mean uh
you've heard noel say that no cancer say
that he said those that you know all
that stuff i mean i mean it just going
back to
the
the little thing that he gave because he
was talking about he wants putin to help
him but the part where he's talking
about how there's no bread in stores and
he's talking about a tiffany's
that's like the only damn store that he
can come up with is tiffany's in his
brain and he's it almost made me think
like he was like
she's banging the guard at tiffany's
just right
it made me think he was like i went to
tiffany's the other day and there was no
bread at tiffany's like no [ __ ] sherlock
like no kidding no there wasn't there's
not a [ __ ] bread aisle in the tiffany
i couldn't get that sandwich at sears to
save my life right right right right
well and then then he says the hardware
store and i'm like man it's been a long
time since anyone's called any store the
what is this the 1960s when is the last
time you called any store like a lowe's
or home depot the hardware store like
come on man it's not hard it reminds me
of the
and it's not a politically
correct joke but norm mcdonald does this
great joke and i'll just share with you
and you know i love norm and he wasn't
always
politically uh are correct so just
you know this is don't quote me on this
but this was his joke it was so funny
because he goes
he goes so a guy walks into a store and
he goes hey do you have any polish
sausage
and then the guy goes
are you polish
and he goes why would you think that
because i want polish sausage so if i
ask for um
you know if i ask for some irish soda
bread does that mean i'm irish
you know you know if i ask for some
swedish meatballs
does
does that mean i'm swedish
if i ask for some italian uh if i ask
for some polish i know if i ask for some
italian um
sausage does that make me italian and
then the guy behind the counter goes
no it's because you're at a hardware
store oh
i i can't do it justice but
it's norm you know
right with the the old the old pollock
jokes and you know there there are
they're uh friends with ukraine you know
they're helping uh having all the
refugees coming into poland and uh you
know that's another issue that these
morons can't figure out because they're
you know they
joe biden said that they want to uh get
a hundred thousand refugees from ukraine
into the united states
and there have the republicans are
having a real tough time because they're
like well
they're white so it's you know it's a
real tough game for them with these
refugees so they're having a real tough
time uh how they're gonna do this um
because you know the brown refugees they
hate those refugees i know but white
refugees they they got a real tough time
to try to figure out how they're going
to square that circle oh and by the way
kevin mccarthy is saying you know joe
biden is doing nothing about the
southern border do you realize that
illegal immigrants are down coming over
the southern border right now
i mean you know
see
these people don't deal in facts they
deal in fox news talking points for
instance i have this friend
and he tweets me
no he texted me this stupid ass
it's it's um
okay so he goes
uh oh uh
you know like at a gas station do not
take off the biden stickers if you voted
for him you should be proud to pay these
prices otherwise do not rip them off
that's considered vandalism you are on
cameras okay so that's what he
that's what he texts me what does he
mean the binding stickers does he mean
the one that says uh i did that kind of
[ __ ]
is that everything
no i think he means like you know joe
biden for president or whatever so then
i go
i i respond i guess joe biden
is president of the whole world you
really should try and understand
capitalism and supply and demand instead
of watching fox news gas in brazil 557 a
gallon germany 870 gallon japan 551 hong
kong 1090 israel 854 australia 591 italy
874 united kingdom 840. no joe biden is
president of none of these countries
glp lies fools believe and that's the
truth they as as the army major always
says they're the poorly educated
well anything that you say
that they can use to basically you know
throw stones at the democratic party and
try to elevate theirs they don't do any
research to see if it's true they just
go let's run with it and the thing is is
that's what fox does
fox news does not put out anything worth
the [ __ ] the fact that they call it news
is a freaking lie you know
and and the bad part about it is there's
a significant amount of people that have
fallen for that and until we can either
educate people
or absolutely just show it to them to
where they can at least see it of course
the hardest part is to get them to look
at it because they keep looking the
other way
uh we continue going down the path that
we're going but
i do believe
that people are waking up
and i i i we have to hope so but i mean
there's also like think about it uh look
at herself walker
bless his heart herself walker
absolutely just dumb as a damn stump uh
an embarrassment
and and this guy is running against
dr
reverend senator warnock
and anybody who listens
to you know senator warnock speak
it is absolutely a beautiful thing to
hear he is so intelligent
and he is just so spot on with the
things that he says and then you look
over here you know if there's a debate
it's going to be and i hope they are but
i guarantee you the republican party
will try to avoid debates like that
because they know that it will
absolutely embarrass herschel walker so
they would rather just run herbie walker
on sound bites
because they know that if he is
successful when he wins senate then it's
no different than like all the
republicans hey you're going to vote yes
yes yes no no yes yes yes no yes no on
these bills that we are going to be
looking at today don't ask why
you're going to do what you're told and
that's what the republican party does
and that's why the republican party
likes people like lauren bobert and
marjorie train rick green they make a
lot of noise and do that kind of [ __ ]
but when it comes to voting they vote
the way they are told to vote and they
know that and that's why you know the
the republican party even remotely tries
to even act like they're supporting them
at all because at the end of the day
they're freaking train wrecks
good as gold thanks for the five bucks
uh she makes a good point i hate to say
it but the constant talk points about
high gas prices without pushback from
thems or what will make people go
republican
just like tony said in the beginning of
the show the dems are the worst at
messaging and they have to get better at
it yeah
you want me to tell you about the gas oh
go ahead go ahead
no no but what she just said it's spot
on i've been telling this for obviously
look if the democrats cannot tell their
victories then we're screwed the
republicans are never going to talk
about the victories of the democratic
party you know joe manchin has just went
ahead and said that he's going to lease
release a million barrels of oil
from our reserves for the next six
months joe biden did you probably i'm
saying joe button
joe mansion
but to ever to lower the price at the at
our energy bills and at the pumps joe
biden is doing that you know and and
he's doing it for the right reasons
but why is the democratic party not
absolutely blasting and saying look
first off you know we know that the
president doesn't dictate the price of
gas but understand that the president
does have the ability to try to mitigate
you know the issues that are going on
and by doing this it's going to help us
at the pumps
that's a victory but they don't say [ __ ]
about it you know i get it in in one
little article but that's it it should
be all over the news
well if you if you want to know that i
always say joe biden doesn't have a
gasoline button on his desk you know
that's how they view it like he's got a
gasoline button i said if he adds a
gasoline button maybe he should get a
health care button and he should push
that button and lower the price of
health care maybe he should have a lot
of buttons on his desk but here's the
thing is if anyone wants someone to
blame and i can't [ __ ] figure this
out to save my life for years and years
and years on gas prices the first thing
that
average americans blame when gas prices
are high are greedy oil companies the
price of crude has dropped and it's
going to continue to drop as joe biden
releases these reserves and as our
allies around
the world release their national
reserves and the price of crude is going
to drop but the price at the pump is
going to stay there that ain't because
joe biden controls the price of this or
controls the price of that it's because
opec and because the gasoline companies
control the price of gas they're the
ones gouging they're the ones taking all
the money they have record profits in
their pockets they're lining their
pockets with your money because you're
blaming joe biden you start to turn your
anger around at the person who can make
a difference and start directing it
towards them you damn right that the the
price at the pump will go down
yeah yeah and that's what needs to
happen and you're right absolutely shale
exxon all those companies are the ones
that are doing it it's not president
biden but the republicans are more than
happy to say biden biden buying because
at the end of the day they're just
trying to win the next
triangle
well
yeah i think he locked up again yep i'm
supposed to be the one locking up i'm
the stutter origin stop it already
stop stealing my act can you can you
guys hear me
yeah
okay all right hey man look i'm i'm in
the middle of the woods man i got the
elon musk [ __ ] but maybe he don't like
me because i sure do drag his raggedy
ass through the garden so much
i might i might use his uh internet but
i still think he's an [ __ ]
well look
i've never i would never applaud susan
collins in my life
but
up until now
i will applaud susan collins because she
is gonna vote yes on kbj which which
takes
you know kamala harris out of the
equation
and and kbj will become
uh you know a justice on the supreme
court that's good news what about
murkowski i think murkowski may also
yeah yeah i believe she is too yeah and
what we need now
is for clarence thomas to freaking take
his fat ass
out of the supreme court
because
i know he won't richard but he should
because what
what his wife did she was involved in
the insurrection yes
there is a conflict of interest he
should step down
period yes here's what needs to happen
first off no matter what sometimes when
you know they're not going to get rid of
him the the senate will never get rid of
him but alexandria castillo cortez has
already come out and said that he either
needs to step down or
she they're going to push for an
impeachment understand that he will get
impeached if that's what he wants his
legacy to be he'll be the second person
on the supreme court to ever be
impeached the first one was like 1810.
if that's what he wants his legacy to be
now he could protect his legacy by
saying i'm stepping down and that's fine
but the make no mistake about it the
republican party will never allow that
and they will do everything in their
power to convince him to weather the
storm and not go anywhere because they
know that if he steps down the democrats
get to be the ones who select the next
supreme court justice and
you know i don't know i i hope that the
democrats go after his ass i hope that
they drag his raggedy ass wife through
the damn garden but uh i mean at the end
if if he wants to be known as the second
person to be impeached on the supreme
court you know then i i say they still
move forward with it
what i think is odd
and i was thinking about this
clarence thomas is an african-american
man
donald trump
has been
horrible
to african americans you know they're
good people on both sides i mean
horrible
the insurrectionists were
running around with confederate flags
she's a white woman and now she's
supporting
people
that don't like black people and she's
and she's married to a black person i
mean what the [ __ ] is wrong with her
john you have to understand donald trump
likes black people that are willing to
sell themselves out to him
donald trump doesn't like the average
african-american donald trump i mean i
mean come on we already know that donald
trump was angered when he walked through
the lobby of one of his hotels and found
african-american construction workers
working because he felt that the white
people will look at black people working
on construction and they may not trust
the level of construction we know donald
trump is a freaking racist but the thing
about it is is
they're more than happy it's the black
guy that they want and that's it that's
what that that that and remember they're
the ones who nominated clarence thomas
and voted for him to become a supreme
court justice in the first place you
know because why because they wanted to
be the first to say look we are all
about supporting people of color when in
actuality they're not but remember
there's some people black people that
fall for that [ __ ] which is why you
see these people standing behind donald
trump wearing blacks for trump t-shirts
that you know they didn't get until they
got there and somebody said hey put this
on and come walk and stand with us and
they allow themselves to be used like
that and that right there is what's the
that right there is the worst part about
it all is that these people allow
themselves to be used by these racist
freaking [ __ ]
it is unbelievable and i don't give a
[ __ ] it's their token black guy
you mean herschel walker is that who
you're talking about marshall walker's
one of them you know kanye west is one
of them [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them oh and uh candace owens
yeah two and christian walker herschel's
son
look took all of them all of them you
know i don't give i give two shits about
none of them i mean at the end of the
day you know what they have done they
they they are setting african americans
back you know and i think the average
african-american absolutely is against
the [ __ ] that they're doing and
saying donald trump hasn't elevated
anybody that are that is of any color
light brown to dark brown out of poverty
ever and he never will
never will but if he can find one out of
a thousand that'll say donald trump's a
good guy then he'll put that freaking
guy on a camera someplace well he'll say
exploit him he'll say there's my black
guy over there there's my black guy
yeah imagine that imagine imagine
somebody not donald trump standing in a
crowd going hey there's my black guy
over there you know that's that's that's
as disrespectful as you get you know but
once again these people
they they just they don't get it they
don't get it you know the lack of
intelligence that we have running around
this country is scary
and you know the other thing that you
know that i pointed out on twitter
is that
out of all the supreme court justices
that we have right now right
two of them
have been accused of sexual assault and
harassment
okay
and they're both
at the republican appointees you know
what i mean
is that surprising though is that
surprising though no but but it's just
such
so indicative of the republican party
you know
it's like
two out of the nine
what
right but here's the thing is i said
this i said this with uh judge brown
jackson with her confirmation hearings
last week i said the reason why
republicans are so pissed off like
lindsey graham he's like he's
complaining white people have it so hard
like brett kavanaugh he he got accused
of of sexual uh harassment and sexual
assault and he got accused of having
parties and amy coney barrett got
accused of hiding behind her religious
dogma to hide her bigotry and like yeah
because that's because they were and
he's like why don't we get to ask judge
brown jackson these questions because
she doesn't she didn't sexually assault
anyone no one's accused her that she
doesn't hide behind her religious she
didn't hide her bigotry she didn't have
bigotry to begin with but she didn't
hide bigotry behind a religious dogma
that's why you can't ask those questions
and that is the difference because
everyone's like oh both parties are the
same they're both [ __ ] that that
right there those confirmation hearings
should give everyone the ammunition that
they need when they're talking to people
out in their communities about how the
parties are different the parties are
different because of the questions that
the republicans had to ask
judge brown jackson they they were so
pissed off that they couldn't ask her
about a secret sexual assault allegation
against her they were mad about it they
were infuriated about it
there's somebody on here linda workman
uh says is garland going to do anything
and i just i think that's something that
we can't let it run up and not say
something let me tell you something
garland is doing everything and i will
tell you that a month ago i would have
said what the hell is he doing but now
we're starting to realize that things
are starting to surface
the chain inside of the department of
justice is unbreakable nobody even knows
what the hell they're even talking about
and then all of a sudden bam they're
there nobody knew that they were going
to freaking raid uh rudy giuliani's
freaking office and get all of his [ __ ]
until they busted through the front
friggin door you know nobody knew that
they were going to freaking indict the
leaders of the proud boys and the oath
keepers until they did
so now we're starting to realize
that the department of justice is just
basically keeping everything close they
get ready to hire 131 new lawyers
because they're going to go after
everything and i'm going to tell you
that the the january 6 commission people
need to understand have no fear about
2022 election in terms of the january
6th convention because the january 6
commission is going to be done with
their investigation before anybody
starts voting in november of this year
and what they're going to do is they're
going to take all the evidence that they
got and they are going to first expose
it on national television they have had
meetings with republican people people
in the trump administration that have
already told them everything that they
want to know and now they're going to
bring them people back sit them in front
of a camera on national television and
those people are going to get asked the
same questions and they're going to have
to tell the truth again and it's going
to start to expose things and then at
the end the the january 6 commission is
going to hand everything over to the
department of justice because the
department of justice is the only ones
that can actually prosecute them for a
crime the january 6th commission can't
it's no different than what's going on
in new york with leticia james leticia
james is going to expose donald trump
for uh tax fraud for insurance fraud and
for for a tax file insurance another and
the thing about it is the only thing
she's going to do is be able to make him
pay back the money that he owes she
cannot prosecute him bragg was the one
that was supposed to prosecute him and
that chicken [ __ ] freaking dropped the
case so hopefully they'll get rid of his
freaking ass sooner than later and
somebody could come in and pick it back
up because they can hold on major
leticia james yes she's doing a civil
thing but if it turns out that donald
trump also is guilty of criminal
activities
she could then turn that over
and then they can go after him yes she
can turn but she can turn it over but
brag has already said he's not going to
do it
she's going to bust his ass and he's
going to have to pay back [ __ ] tons of
money we know that he's got stuff they
had they had 30 some thousand square
feet worth freaking 350 million dollars
and then when it come time today gone uh
get taxed they reduced it on the paper
to eleven thousand all the things that
they did show absolute criminal intent
but at the end of the day that bragg's
[ __ ] bag who who actually got the
position because he was talking about he
was going to be strong on crime and then
gets in there and says nah i don't want
to mess with that that [ __ ] bag needs to
go
well i asked popock a favorite here on
on this show i asked popock last week he
came on my show and i i actually after
this news broke um with the pomerantz
where he where he's uh his the the
letter of resignation that he sent out
he basically said yeah trump committed
[ __ ] crimes and you should indict him
and i'm resigning because you won't that
was basically what primal rants is and
so i asked popock about that pop said
that
yeah this brag situation is a thing but
the the thing is is that the governor
new york can either tell brag to kick
rocks um if if he won't do what he's
supposed to do because she's the
governor and she can tell she can uh
fire pace and and reappoint a deal or
what she can do is appoint a special
prosecutor and i believe if i'm not
mistaken here and i need to get pope
back back on her maybe you can have
bobok uh back on that's kind of
happening
on saturday yeah so you might ask him
then he uh um
i think that they were supposed to have
they had one meeting with the governor's
office the d.a did and i think they were
supposed to have another meeting with
the governor's office now i don't know
if the governor is going to say you
either prosecute or i'll spank your ass
or you know i'm not sure exactly how all
this stuff goes you know i'm not privy
to these conversations i'm just
surmising here but i would imagine that
the governor of new york would say if
there's crimes there prosecute it or
i'll find someone who will i hope so
look i hope so i hope you were
absolutely right because at the end of
the day we cannot allow donald trump to
get away with this because i don't give
a [ __ ] if it's the president or not
nobody is supposed to be above the law
and we're watching it happen in real
time and it's not right you know the
mere fact that we know for a fact that
loffler and purdue committed insider
trading and nobody done
because guess what we found out that
members of congress who get insider
information are allowed to go do stock
trades and [ __ ] like that and that's
[ __ ] you know and that's why there's
some people now trying to push
legislation that says freaking you're
not allowed to buy stock and [ __ ] when
you're a freaking elected official and
you shouldn't be able to i'm sick and
tired of these people that run for
office because they're supposed to be a
representative of the people but all
they give a [ __ ] about themself you know
and that's what's wrong with our country
that's what's wrong with our government
and if we don't get track of this
[ __ ] we could lose this you know
there's a lot of things going on in this
country right now that should scare the
[ __ ] out of people and i'm going to tell
you stupidity is is something that
should be that should scare everybody
and we have freaking we got an abundance
of that [ __ ]
jeanette cook
brett kavanaugh has 200 000 debt
that disappeared days before his
nomination shouldn't we care who paid
that i don't know why that hasn't been
investigated there's so much corruption
going on in the republican party
it's like
every every day there's new
stuff that comes out
it's it's amazing
it's amazing just how corrupt one party
could be
ninety two thousand dollar country cub
fees were paid two hundred thousand
dollar credit card debt was paid off 1.2
million mortgage was paid off
i mean yeah i think it's important that
we need to get to the bottom of that
[ __ ] that sounds like a pretty good
deal over 300 000 and all you get to do
is all you have to do is be a supreme
court justice that's a pretty good damn
deal don't you think absolutely i mean i
i would take that deal would you take
that deal i mean i wouldn't make the
decisions that that [ __ ] box would make
but i take that deal you pay off 300 000
of my debt and i get to be a supreme
court justice that sounds like a pretty
damn good deal and that right there goes
to show that that's criminal right you
know and it and and and we should not
just give that a pass
you know and and and we also know that
you know in terms of the rules and
regulations of the supreme court they
pretty much write their own tickets
they get to decide what's right and
wrong you know i mean
it's absolute sickening and it's a shame
you know i think we should pack the
court one one suggestion i've heard is
that
um
we should uh and i think it was my
suggestion is we should add four more
seats and what we should do is joe biden
should appoint four more black women to
those seats um just to [ __ ] in their
cereal [ __ ] them i mean just a [ __ ] zero
give them give them four more black
women to nominate
yeah right right i'll tell you what if
we win
if we
take the senate
you know which it it's very possible if
we do
i damn well think that they're gonna add
more
seats to the supreme court i'm telling
you and i think they're gonna abolish
the filibuster too i don't think that
they're gonna try that unless the
republicans try something like friggin
you know making uh you know
throwing up throwing roe v wade out the
window or something like that but at the
end of the day you're also gonna think
it's not just one or two seats i mean i
think that i think tim ryan will win i'm
hoping val demings will take out
uh you know mark rubio i hope sarah
godlewski john fetterman is doing
phenomenal but at the end of the day you
know we would need to win a good
you know
nine or ten seats in the senate to be
able to finally be able to tell the
republicans you all can sit your ass
down you know and not not find you know
somebody throwing a monkey wrench and
i'll tell you this any time
even if we get close to it
that still allows people like joe
manchin and kirsten cinema to be able to
sell their soul to the other side to
hold the democrats back and if you don't
think that the republicans are willing
to write those checks well you're deeply
mistaken
debbie garrison
there should be 13 supreme court
justices because there are 13 district
courts that's why you had four you had
four [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them yeah yeah you had
four you had four and i i mean if it
were me joe biden should probably
nominate four black women to those four
seats and the reason why is because
black women are the most highly educated
uh demographic in this country because
they have to work 500 times harder than
any [ __ ] else out there just
because they are black women but here's
but here's what i'll well hold on tony
before you give
gabet mojo says
uh i'd like to see
a native american judge absolutely i i'm
not opposed to it i'm not opposed to it
i'll tell you two of my picks that would
be my picks if it were me and i and i
got to tell joe biden new to pick i
would pick well maybe three i would pick
barack obama
hillary clinton and and hunter biden's
laptop that's who i would probably have
um be the supreme i'm sarah i mean i
mean why not why not they were really
pissing their cheerios if they had to
question hunter biden's laptop wouldn't
that really [ __ ] with them
do they really think that it's illegal
to own a laptop i've i've wondered this
for a long time they act like they're
like hunter biden owns a [ __ ] laptop
did you hear this yeah and you know what
he did do you know what he did guys on
that laptop he sent [ __ ] emails he
sent emails on his laptop isn't that
crazy and that crazy that son of a [ __ ]
that son of a [ __ ] what is this
it amazes me that that's still a topic
who gives a [ __ ]
you know and here's some more good news
a better o'rourke is starting to uh
get closer and closer to uh
to be an even if not eve if not even
uh
more than um
greg abbott you know are you talking
about in the polls there's a new poll
yeah oh i gotcha
that would be awesome if greg abbott
gets to go
that that's an important race
and uh
you can speak to this because you've
been in races before but that's an
important race and it's not just because
of the uh
of the governor's race but it's the up
ballot for the senator and then it's the
down ballot like in the legislator like
to really make change in the state of
texas because i i think i think the more
they get people registered in texas the
bluer it becomes and that those down bow
change that whole dynamic in texas and
think about this in 2024
if if if texas is blue there ain't a
[ __ ] republican in this goddamn
country that can win if democrats picked
texas new york and california they're
completely [ __ ]
and and i'll tell you right now you know
you were absolutely right the
republicans
did this
we completely took our eyes off of down
ballot races the democrats did and and
the truth is is i'm still fighting that
battle now is i'm still trying to get
the democratic party to say hey we need
to support people in middle america you
know because if we don't then we get the
republicans have been focusing on
putting county commissions boards of
education you know secretaries of state
i mean
you know right now you've got a person
that's running against raffensberger in
georgia all because raffenberger decided
that he wasn't going to follow through
with the crimes that donald trump wanted
him to follow through with and because
of that then all of a sudden you've got
donald trump you know supporting a
republican that is a complete
you know against rappensburg we had a
hope
that people understand that these down
ballot races are important and they need
to absolutely get some support
do you feel like do you feel like those
races like were to the trump the trump
candidate do you want them to win the i
mean i kind of want them to win the
primary right so that way in the fall
when everyone's getting indicted they
got to pay for the [ __ ] crimes that
trump committed like they're like yeah
we're trump we love trump and they elect
them because they're a trump candidate
and then in the fall they got to pay for
all those [ __ ] crimes yeah i think
in the general midterm yeah i think
that'd be great and at the end of the
day i mean i i don't know if it's if
you're looking in georgia where you're
talking about kemp and purdue i still
feel comfortable that kemp
uh
kemp kemp was gonna beat purdue but you
know at the end of the day
uh i still think that i think stacey
abrams is gonna do it
but now in other in other races like
let's say
let's who is anybody who was running in
with herschel walker walkers leading the
polls and that right there get out of
here really oh no no live in georgia
does he he doesn't even live there he's
from texas
he's he's actually leading in the polls
right now
and but the thing about it is is that if
he wins
it'll be an embarrassment because
i mean warnock is going to destroy him a
debate will be almost as if it will
almost be like that people will pity him
no way he debates him no way you think
he'd debate him i don't think he will
well i don't know maybe he's that stupid
maybe
now when you say that he's leading in
the polls is that against warnock
no no no it's under the prime minister
oh okay okay because i i because i would
find that hard to believe
yeah but what tony is saying makes a lot
of sense if donald trump's people win
but we know that that during the general
election
they're only going to say one thing
and that's donald trump was robbed that
shit's not going to go over there's a
lot of republicans that have finally
woke up and realized that that is some
of the biggest [ __ ] out there and if
you want to run on that good because i
don't think anybody that donald trump
supports because donald trump's only
going to support them if they basically
say that the number one problem in this
country is that trump lost well hell you
see that with mo brooks he d
he jumped mo brooks in a heartbeat
because mo brooks wouldn't play ball and
have you heard the person that's that
he's supporting against snow brooks
oh i'm sure he's a dandy oh no it's a
female oh i'm sure she's a [ __ ] dandy
dude absolutely is nuttier than a [ __ ]
house rat you know oh gottier than a
squirrel turd huh yeah yeah man yeah
it's it's embarrassing it's like that
one guy and i forget what race he's in
they almost got into a fist fight you
know because this guy and the guy oh he
did two tours in iraq oh give a [ __ ] you
know he gets up and he's like he's he he
gets to this freaking guy that's like 75
year olds face and they're having
they're about ready to have a trump off
you know it's embarrassing embarrassing
and the thing is if that guy wins
he's a complete another joke like he's
standing there and and one of the one of
his he did a debate and he was like he
was like
i went all the way to texas to make sure
that i put my eyes on the counting of
the ballots because donald trump was
done wrong and the opponent says
who does that you know
really you you're from this state and
you went down there to watch them count
the boats you're a freaking [ __ ] well
they're for states rights they're for
states rights you know they're they know
give me a [ __ ] break these people
don't believe anything they've never
believed anything they they don't have
any convictions at all they never have
it's always been [ __ ] they've always
hid their their fascism behind thin bail
conservatism talking about tax cuts and
budgets and and deficits it's all
[ __ ] it always has been [ __ ]
yeah it's josh mandel i'm telling you
this dude is a favorite that guy's gonna
ask him
hey hey don't offend [ __ ] don't
offend [ __ ] god damn
he's one of those guys that play that
you know i served two tours i don't give
two shits how many tours you served in
combat if you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
if you're willing to give away our
democracy to a friggin freaking [ __ ]
like donald trump then you know what you
freaking you didn't you get an obvious
you don't get it you don't get it he
didn't learn anything from his two tours
in freaking combat and then again too
you know half he's them politicians
and i don't give a [ __ ] most politicians
out there that want to check that block
of being in the military they're they're
freaking military jag officers you know
and then they want to tell everybody you
know i served two tours in combat yeah
in the alpha palace you know where you
friggin
basically you know the worst day in
combat for you was when starbucks didn't
[ __ ] deliver it
they never right
thanks for the two dollars he says
crazier than a cockeyed road lizard
these are all these like hillbilly terms
i'm getting over here
i say nuttier than a squirrel turd you
know
that's that's always my go-to
with these trump humping
idiots oh my god
it's like i'm telling you
every time i'm like you know every time
i go to the pub it's another
like lunatic like who says something
like just the other day now keep in mind
i have a transgender child okay
this guy is so stupid so he's sitting
across from me
and he says
um
you know if a dog
has his balls
cut off
he doesn't become a woman
you know he doesn't become female and
i'm like
what is is that some kind of transgender
slant you [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah
like you know and and then like and i
almost want to go
you know
that's so [ __ ] stupid because
even
even that analogy because this dog still
has a penis you idiot it's because they
cut the balls oh it doesn't mean
but it doesn't doesn't matter like
but they're so stupid it's like arguing
with
and and he's a staunch trump supporter
of course you how many how many people
how many people over the last two years
how many people that were trans
how many have been caught sneaking into
the opposite restroom and assaulting
young children how many none none none
you know i mean you know what you've got
to be a special kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
to want to attack
an or a group of people that absolutely
they don't
all they want to do
is be accepted
all they want to do is be treated fair
they're not asking for more you know
there was a woman that was interviewed
outside of a trump rally and the guy was
like you know they're like i don't think
it's right for the people in the lgbtq
community
to to get all this stuff what do you
mean you mean like have everything like
you got yeah i don't think they should
because because we've worked harder for
that you know [ __ ] they're the ones
that are working hard to be accepted in
society and at the end of the day
it's the stupidity and anybody like the
guy you were just talking about just
showed how ignorant he was when he
opened his freaking mouth you know i'm
just saying you know what i believe i
treat everybody with respect how about
that unless you unless you do something
that makes me lose my respect for you
and then go [ __ ] yourself well that's
why it's white male fragility for sure
and i said it earlier what's really
strange about all this transgender
bathroom stuff is how these [ __ ]
morons are so goddamn obsessed with
someone else's genitalia in the bathroom
i can't i can't even imagine focusing
when i go to the bathroom i go take a
[ __ ] and i'm out of there right like i
don't i don't stick around and
concentrate on what other people's
genitalia is or what it is
let me ask you guys because everyone
talks about people going in the
bathrooms and they've been doing this
[ __ ] where they do this um they do this
and the marjorie taylor green hoof foot
green did this at the last nazi rally i
mean trump rally excuse me um
the last nazi rally they had in georgia
he she said pete buddha judge and her
husband go in a little girl's bathroom
number one i don't i don't i've never
been in a in a public place like a gas
station and there'd be a little girl's
room number one there's a woman's and a
man's but i i have done this before
where there it's a one [ __ ] hitter
you know you go in then there's one
there's one commode in the women's
there's one commode in the man
and you've been on the road for a while
and you know what i'm talking about boys
maybe you had taco bell you know down
the road and you know it's really it's
really hitting you hard like you're
you're aching you got a crap so bad
right and you go in the bathroom and the
dude's bathroom is locked right and
you're you're either going to [ __ ] your
drawers
or you may have to go
oh yeah why are you gonna are you gonna
[ __ ] your drawers are you gonna go in
the girls you know the one the one
toilet commode and lock the door and do
your best of course you're not gonna do
it right there you're not gonna do it
right there in the bathroom so this
nonsense about
bathrooms is all [ __ ] it always has
been [ __ ] it's this it's these
republican weirdos who are focused on
other people's genitalia and other
people's sexuality and other people's
gender they are completely obsessed what
other people are doing because
it's a single
uh i think we lost nails by sherry
thanks for the two bucks stacey abrams
will have the trekkies vote
i don't get that do you
get it i don't know i don't know what
that what that means
i actually to get going tony go ahead
and plug anything that you want oh yeah
so so uh if you guys want to watch my
show just go over to thetonymichaels.com
um you'll find all the links there you
can follow us on twitter at toni
michael's pod you can follow me
at d tony michaels as well uh just you
can go google the tony michaels and find
the uh the youtube channel
uh you know watch the show it's every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and now that
we're associated with midas touch we're
on midas touch's facebook page we
broadcast from there every single
weekday monday through friday two hours
every single day it's a live stream
we're live i don't jack around we go
live two hours
every single day and tomorrow tomorrow
in our second hour we're gonna have a
bonehead madness we did a competition
this week
and uh today if you want to vote on the
bonehead champion it's tucker carlson
and ron desantis in the final game for
bonehead champion um just go to
tonymichael's pod on twitter and you can
vote for that game thanks a lot for
having me on john i appreciate it it's
been fun i i i hope you uh
i didn't cost too much or no it doesn't
matter oh okay mr double o seven mil
thanks for five bucks yes stacey abrams
was the president of the world in an
episode of star trek i didn't know that
yeah she's an author too she's an author
too i had no idea uh about that either
she it uh what's her what's her author's
handle she has it's not i don't know she
ain't writing under stacey abrams she's
right but anyway tony uh you got my
mom's approval so really
go ahead and plug anything that you want
you had a couple people asking how come
i'm not on youtube i am on youtube it's
oh jetta live we had to basically
completely do a new page because a
freaking jackass is always trying to
report stupid [ __ ] so it's ojed alive
all right guys listen thank you so much
for coming on i love you both thank you
we'll see you guys
all right
all right the great tony michaels the
great richard ojeda i thank them for
coming on the show
uh hey pontius from twitch uh also yes i
saw somebody posted that jim carrey
lambasted
will smith and i love jim carrey i i had
the opportunity
to meet uh jim carrey and
talk to him he's a sweetheart of a man
all right i want to thank my moderator
today benny loco i don't think nikki b
was here but i'll thank her anyway
i also want to thank my sponsor bet
online.ag i want to thank all of you for
the generous super chats and all of you
for contributing
in the show i'll be back on saturday at
noon i think with popock
and uh somebody else and i have a great
guest coming on next week all right
y'all i'll see you this is stuttering